Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
So, Game of Thrones Episode 1 Q&A.
Lots of people going crazy about all kinds of stuff.
Mostly Melisandre - Sand Snake stuff.
So just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet.
There were a couple questions that everybody had
so I'll just answer those up front first.
Melisandre's choker is part of her glamour
it requires a physical object but glamouring and masking someone's appearance are two different things.
As you saw, it's a very powerful form of illusion.
So it's like, wait:
The time that Stannis and Gendry had sex with her
Does that mean that they were really having sex with an old woman?
No.
It doesn't really work that way.
Glamour's actually much more powerful than that
it actually physically changes her body.
So, when they were having sex with her
they were actually having sex with this person right here, physically.
But in reality
she is ancient.
But physically in this moment, when she's wearing this glamour
she's a young person.
So, one of the really big examples of this in the books
during Dance with Dragons is when she glamours Mance Rayder
and you get into the Pink Letter storyline.
Now because they might do a version of that on the TV show, I don't wanna get into that too much.
But her taking the glamour off at the end of the episode
isn't really evidence that her power has gone away.
She probably does that every once in awhile.
But I know a lot of you asked about clues in the books
that say that, y'know maybe she doesn't sleep at all.
So why is she sleeping if she's not supposed to be sleeping at all?
I think right now she's just shaken
so she's like:
Okay, I need a minute to collect myself.
So that's why she climbs into bed looking the way she does.
Otherwise, if Stannis were still alive and sleeping in a room near her
she would probably keep the glamour on
or probably wouldn't sleep at all.
Questions though.
Here we go.
First one.
Juntartful:
How did the little dagger kill the big dude with the one stab?
Yeah, it definitely sucked that House Martell went down so fast
but I think that was just the show telling you
that they're not that important.
Like being a cool character
being important
two very different things.
I think the show just decided that it wasn't gonna do a big Martell storyline.
It wasn't gonna do Master Plan stuff
so it wanted to tell you in the quickest way possible
that they were just gonna move on to something else.
So it's like:
Okay, yeah these are important characters
but this is our way of telling you
that they're not gonna be important in the long scheme of things.
I think the even more upsetting thing though
is that they made Doran Martell seem like a really boring character.
Like, he pretends to be boring because of his gout
he can't move so he seems really feeble.
He uses that to his advantage when he's dealing with other people
because they underestimate him
but what the show has done, is turn him from a person who pretends be boring
to a person who is actually boring.
And I think that's more worthy of complaint than say like the Sand Snakes getting on the boat with Trystane.
Speaking of which.
Next question
Chriser asks:
Anyone know how the Sand Snakes ended up on the boat with Trystane?
So, there was a big question about this.
Y'know, which boat was he on?
Was he on the boat with Jaime?
So, I think that he was on a different boat
just to explain that.
At the end of last season
it seemed like he got on the same boat as Jaime and Myrcella.
So that's why everybody was really confused.
Wait, if they were on the boat with Jaime
then how come Jaime didn't say anything about it to Cersei?
How come we didn't see any interaction there?
I think the easiest answer that makes sense
is that he just escorted Myrcella onto that boat
then he turned around
came back to dock
and took a different ship.
So that's not necessarily the best explanation
but that's the best one I can think of.
He was on a different boat and when he got on that different boat the Sand Snakes also got on that boat with him.
Like, he thought initially that they were travelling him
because he wasn't surprised to see them when they first walked into his room.
He didn't think anything weird was going on.
Next question
Fish Tank Girl asks:
In the beginning of the episode when Jon's body is removed from the ground
Davos looks really long at the place where his body was lying
it must mean something.
They seem a point of making sure that you notice
he looks really long at the impression of Jon Snow's body in the snow
foreshadowing for something.
Yeah, so the show has to do things in a visual way that you wouldn't necessarily do in the books.
Like, the books have POV chapters
so when you wanna foreshadow something
you just have a character think about that
but you can't really do that on the TV show.
Usually when the camera lingers on something it can mean a couple different things
but in the case of Jon Snow's body
just - because we all have this theory that he's coming back
we definitely think that they're foreshadowing that
and I do agree that's what they're foreshadowing.
Like, this isn't as simple as it seems.
There were a couple storylines in the episode where they talked about dead bodies.
You have Cersei talking about her mother's dead body
about how it turns black
talking about Myrcella's body.
Then you have Ramsay standing over Myranda's dead body for a couple minutes before he's like:
Yep, feed her to the dogs.
So one - the fact that no-one has talked about burning Jon Snow's body
or it decaying
or anything like that
tells you a lot that you need to know.
Like, he's just gonna be chilling here
waiting for something.
Most of what's gonna happen with his body
I think will come through Bran's character via flashbacks
like Tower of Joy stuff
and Melisandre in present day.
So just watch for the next couple of episodes.
There's still gonna be a lot of suspense surrounding what's going on with him.
Next question
Justin asks:
What about the stuff with the religious group? Is that in the books at all?
Well, there are other Red Priests in Meereen
there's a big red temple.
Maybe we'll see the inside of it.
Just, you have to remember that's the dominant religion in the East.
In addition to the Red Priest that we saw in Episode 1
there are two other Red Priestesses that they cast.
One of them is the High Priestess
so we might learn more about the inner-workings of the church.
Next question
Tyrael asks:
I'm curious who the leader of the Harpies is
I think it's Daario.
Yeah, I would say people are generally split
a lot of people think that it might be Varys
a lot of people think that it might be Daario
it'd be really interesting if it was Daario
but I'm not expecting that.
He just seems way too hopeful about what the world is gonna look like after Daenerys conquers it
and I don't think that he'd try to cause so much chaos in the city if he wanted to bring that outcome.
Varys is also an unlikely candidate
given that he wants to bring about the Targaryen Restoration so much
so I have a feeling that we'll meet the Harpy pretty soon
but it'll be someone that we haven't met yet
it'll be a new character relative to this season.
Next question
Renora asks:
The Dothraki's "Best things in the world" reminded me of Monty Python's "What have the Romans ever done for us?"
Yeah, that's actually
that might have been what they were going for.
If you remember in Season 4
they actually had another Monty Python reference.
It's a really deep easter-egg because you would have had to have been able to speak High Valyrian
to understand what he was saying.
When the knight rides out and is taunting Daario
he's actually speaking the Frenchman's taunts
he's doing that bit from Monty Python
in High Valyrian.
Like, they translated Monty Python into High Valyrian and that's what he's shouting when he's shouting at Daario here
before Daario takes him down.
So, yes I totally believe they are doing a version of that with these Dothraki
but "What have the Romans done for us?"
is just a bit where it's like:
The Romans suck.
Well yeah but they did build the roads
and they did do all these other things
but yeah what have they ever done for us?
Besides all these other things.
So that's kinda what the Dothraki are doing.
So when they release the DVD or y'know maybe the person who was responsible
for creating the Dothraki language will say:
Yeah I translated the Monty Python bit into Dothraki
and that's what they're speaking
even though the subtitles say something else
Next question
DR asks:
Melisandre's necklace was off during her bath.. please explain.
So, a lot of you were asking about this
because last season she was in a bathtub without her necklace on
and she still looked young.
What's the deal?
I think the easiest explanation is that she was just using
like a combination of potions.
Look at all the weird bottles that she has in the background here
so my guess is that there's a little more to the glamour
than just wearing the jewel
like it goes a little beyond that
They actually
they showed these bottles right here too
so maybe there's a potion aspect to it too
but that's just my interpretation
Next question
Chocolate asks:
Do you think Arya will get her sight back this season?
What do you think she has to do to get it back?
In the context of the TV show
she'll probably have to pull off some really badass hit
but if you're just talking about the books
I think she has to get to this place spiritually.
The Many-Faced God is an actual god
like he does have power
there's a mystical aspect to what they do
that they haven't really explained on the show yet.
So I think it's just a combination of physical, mental, spiritual training that she has to get through
she has to quote unquote "Become a Jedi"
the same way that Bran is becoming a Jedi
just in like the visual way that they would do on the show
but when she fully becomes a faceless person
that's when her sight will come back.
Next question
Nikola asks:
Can Melisandre be some old Targaryen?
I really like that idea but no
I think she's just really ancient.
When people are talking about Melisandre secretly being a Targaryen
I totally love all these theories about other people being secret Targaryens
besides Jon Snow
like Tyrion for instance.
But when they're talking about Melisandre
the idea is that she might be the daughter of the Bloodraven and Shiera Seastar.
So she's connected to this character right here who's a really big figure in ASOIAF
just in general
y'know forget what's going on right now
it's just a way to explain how she's connected to the greater war of ice and fire
because the Bloodraven is such a big part of that.
And if you haven't seen my Bloodraven videos
the Bloodraven is one of the bastards of Aegon Targaryen IV
so I'll just say I don't totally think the show is gonna go in this direction
I mean it might but I don't think it will.
Usually the explanations the TV show goes with
tend to be a lot simpler
so I think along those lines
they'll just state that she's really ancient
so she has been studying the prophecies for a long, long time.
Next question
Melt asks:
Will Ser Jorah turn into the Fantastic 4 this season?
You're talking about the Thing
like the Greyscale covering him.
No I actually think he'll make it to the end of the series.
The idea is that when he and Daario are talking about living to see Daenerys conquer the earth
and he's like:
Yeah I would love to see that
like he secretly doesn't think he's gonna live to see that because of the Greyscale.
If we get that shortened Season 8
I think that Jorah would live to see the end of that
but by that time he would be so far gone
that he would try to go out in a blaze of glory.
Like he is pretty sure that he's gonna die really soon
but at the pace it's going I definitely think he's gonna be around for a couple more years.
Thankyou everyone for submitting questions
these are always a ton of fun to do
y'know generally each episode there's gonna be like a couple big questions
but I'll try and hit everything as we go along.